my name is grace Pfeiffer I'm a junior
majoring in philosophy and religion our
speaker tonight
Matthew B Crawford is a senior fellow at
the Institute for Advanced Studies in
culture at the University of Virginia in
a motorcycle mechanic and custom parts
fabricator he earned his BS in physics
at the University of California at Santa
Barbara and a PhD in political
philosophy from the University of
Chicago a contributing editor at the New
Atlantis dr. Crawford has written for
numerous publications including the New
York Times Magazine the American
interest and the Hedgehog review he is
the author of shop class as Soulcraft an
inquiry into the value of work which was
named editor's choice by the Financial
Times of London and most recently the
world beyond your head on becoming an
individual in an age of distraction
please join me in welcoming dr. Crawford
[Applause]
well if you've made it here to the
bitter end of our conference I think it
means you probably have a taste for
dystopia I'm really very happy to be
here at Hillsdale and it's not just
because I really like Eagles I I was
over in the library and I took a photo
in which I managed to get five Eagles in
one frame that's a lot Evil's now it's
really because Hillsdale is a place that
has put a concern for self government at
the very center of its mission and I
think that's precisely the concern that
can help us get a handle on what I take
to be the troubling logic of artificial
intelligence now one way you could sort
of find your way into this political
dimension of AI would be to talk about
say smart cities as a term that we're
hearing a lot what's meant by that is
that the whole physical plant an
infrastructure of a city your behavior
in it your movements through it will be
orchestrated by an urban operating
system that is financed built and
controlled by a cartel of tech companies
rather than democratic institutions I
think the proper way to think about that
is as a transfer of sovereignty but
that's not what I'm going to talk about
quiet I want to talk about the effect
that AI is likely to have on the habits
and dispositions of self-government that
underlie our political order and I want
to get at this by drilling down into one
very particular area that's been marked
for automation and that's driving
now I'm someone who enjoys driving I'm
guessing some of you probably do as well
which might prompt you to think about
what we're being asked to give up maybe
it's not much maybe it's something
pretty trivial but at the risk of
stating my conclusion before I've argued
for it I think this one narrow domain is
instructive for thinking about what's at
stake more broadly and that is the move
to make skilled and intelligent human
action obsolete in the name of a
rationalist utopia one that takes a dim
view of human beings and their native
capacities so these remarks are drawn
from a book I'm currently writing titled
why we drive toward a philosophy of the
open road and when I say open road it
might say open I mean to invoke the
space for human agency that's left open
when people are left to their own
devices so in this brief talk I'm going
to focus on different ways of
coordinating traffic as instantiating
different forms of human rationality
which in turn express and support
different types of political culture
close your eyes if it helps and imagine
a typical suburban thoroughfare traffic
is light you're at an intersection most
of the cars are stopped waiting what are
they waiting for
well of course they're waiting for the
light to change we do a lot of this if
you're in a hurry or prone to impatience
as I am to sit there for minutes when
you can see perfectly well the approach
of cars from every direction requires a
certain amount of emotional labor the
emptiness of the intersection invites
movement but the law prohibits it
there's a conflict between what reason
prescribes and the particular
circumstances in the law which is
indifferent to these circumstances you
feel this as an arbitrary restriction on
the movement of your body
trapped animal so here's a radical
thought experiment what if we used our
blessed eyeballs to determine if it's
okay to turn left through an
intersection in our brains okay I want
to show you something
this is an intersection in Addis Ababa
Ethiopia autonomous intersection
management try to see for the future
very busy streets watch the pedestrians
okay you get the basic idea so there's
no markings of any kind on the pavement
no curbs no control lights and what you
see is a spectacle of improvisation and
flow that's beautiful to behold they
merely slow down pay attention and find
their way through the efficiency of it
is stunning now pause to think about
that isn't efficiency the very claim
made on behalf of our overgrown thicket
of traffic control the putative benefit
that justifies it with the Odyssey bah
the intersection is a point of
comparison we may be emboldened to ask
does every possible path within a
parking lot and of ingress and egress
from a parking lot need to be determined
by curbs and islands every intersection
of the cross street with a thoroughfare
controlled by the batch turn-taking and
forced by an eight-way traffic light
I've traveled the world a fair bit and I
don't think I've ever seen anything like
the inefficiency of the over-regulated
American suburb which we call the land
of the free and home of the brave now
maybe related in the last few years
red-light cameras have sprouted up at
many of the major intersections where I
live in Virginia these have been
proliferating throughout the u.s. they
would seem to express a tacit
recognition that our compliance with
this kind of traffic control must be
secured through surveillance and the
threat of fines because it is not
reasonable now at present automated
traffic enforcement consists of two
elements red-light cameras and photo
radar for speeding and I go and do this
in some depth in the book but I'm just
going to give you a few highlights in
fiscal year 2016 the District of
Columbia took in over a hundred million
dollars from these cameras
and that's fairly typical the rationale
offered by the police is of course
safety and they take great offense at
the suggestion that money might be
driving it yet it seems to be
intersections where the red-light
cameras were installed were selected not
because they were especially prone to
accidents but rather because they had
the greatest volume of flow and the
shortest yellow lights and wherever this
has been looked into by investigative
journalists as has been the case the
duration of a yellow light is something
traffic in engineers consider very
carefully as the frequency of accidents
at an intersection is very sensitive to
this variable which they call amber time
now in the literature they refer to the
dilemma zone the light turns yellow and
you have to decide if you're going to
proceed through or break and the more
compressed that window is the more
unpredictable the behavior of the driver
in front of you the Chicago Tribune
hired researchers at Texas A&M to
conduct a study of Chicago's red-light
camera system they found that the city
routinely placed cameras at
intersections that had few of any injury
related crash problems leaving the
cameras little room to improve safety at
the same time they found unnecessary
cameras at more than 70 intersections
prompted many drivers to slam on the
brakes and efforts to avoid an automated
ticket causing a significant increase in
injury related rear-end crashes near
cameras throughout the city and of
course Chicago being Chicago it was also
discovered that the city manager was
getting a kickback of 10 grand for every
camera installed I was research going
back 10 years recently confirmed shows
that increasing amber times by just half
a second from three to three and a half
seconds resulted in a decrease in
accidents of up to 25 percent and a
decrease in red light violations of up
to 40% and doing this is free but
evidently free safety
isn't nearly as appealing to the
authorities as free money in many cities
has been found that when the red-light
cameras go up the amber times are
reduced now the company that dominates
this market is red flex traffic systems
based in Australia they install the
cameras at little or no cost to a city
monitor them process the images and
generate the citations and coach the
local authorities to say the right
things about the importance of saving
lives and they take about a third of the
proceeds okay so there's nothing new
about municipal corruption and it isn't
especially interesting still there's a
generalization to be drawn from these
cases sometimes rules are deliberately
formulated to be at odds with
reasonableness by parties who have an
interest in the conflict this creates
the idea that decision-making can be
removed from human beings is a bit of
mystification what machines do is follow
the laws of physics they do however
offer a screen of neutrality in an
appearance of necessity behind which the
operation of human judgment becomes
harder to make out and harder to hold to
account the case of Chicago is
instructive as the nature of the
algorithmic control the end being served
by it wasn't covered only because the
Tribune had the resources to hire
forensic engineers so it turned out the
city had adjusted the assumptions used
in the standard equations to determine
amber times whenever there's a program
of subjecting human activities to
rational control we do well to ask if
this really accomplishes an increase in
the rationality of the system or an
increase in control or rather a transfer
of control through a dislocation of the
activity of reasoning away from
individuals with the transfer of control
comes a transfer
wealth to whoever's in charge of the
algorithm and this is highly germane to
the way we experience public authority
increasingly it seems to be exercised on
behalf of a trans global tribe that may
as well be located in Australia is at
City Hall Authority has a sociological
address more than a geographical one and
I think a growing awareness of this
contributed to the populist earthquake
of 2016 I said earlier that our
compliance with the kind of traffic
control predicated on an excess of rule
following must be secured through
surveillance and the threat of fines
because it's not reasonable how do we
experience this compliance it has an
entirely different character from the
kind of citizen lis deference based on
shared rationality that emerges
naturally among people who need to
cooperate and this difference gets to
the heart of what it means to be free
the oddest about the intersection
displays an impressive set of human
qualities precisely those capacities for
judgment and cooperation that are
systematically undermined by the
modernist enthusiasm for systems of
rational control that can be projected
from afar superimposed on the landscape
treated as a grid of predetermined moves
these superimpositions tend to receive
reflexive deference because we have no
alternative vocabulary or conceptual
frame for thinking about our common life
beyond that of administration this
inarticulate see leaves us unable to
resist top-down projects hatched by
various functionaries who nurse and
visions of order and have no qualms
about imposing them on a populace they
regard as unruly and incompetent this
has a cumulative effect on our character
if we're educated into rule following
with
efficient rigger perhaps we'll lose
entirely that physiological response
appropriate to a trapped animal maybe
this is the socialization appropriate to
a modern society but how far do we want
to go do we want to invoke the fact of
human adaptability clearly we can put up
with quite a lot as a legitimizing
principle for the indefinite remaking of
human life according to rationalist
dreams Ivan Illich wrote of the rising
cost of fitting man to the service of
his tools increasing manipulation of man
becomes necessary to overcome the
resistance of his vital equilibrium he
writes it takes the form of educational
medical and administrative therapies now
when you're sitting in traffic such
therapies have to be self applied we all
have our techniques for getting our Zen
on our approach to traffic control
confess serve as a window into a more
general trend a creeping transformation
in the character of public authority
invariably whatever entity public or
private is empowered to pursue dreams of
order understands itself as benevolent
and just as reliably the effect of its
work is to extend the purview of its own
authority too often this comes at the
expense of some customary practice or
informal accommodation that has served
us well enough without expert tutelage
but such folk practices have no Lobby in
the concepts we need to defend them
enjoy little currency worse the very
fact that they are long-established
is an offense to the idea of progress
the progress promised often turns out to
be illusory but the enforced
obsolescence of our native skills quite
real clearly when viewed through the
categories of too
dey's established political options the
argument I'm making here would have to
count as libertarian but it doesn't
proceed from a naive faith in the
generative effects of disorder disorder
is bad what I mean to argue is that the
project for rational control rests on a
very thin conception of what reason
consists of and to narrow a view of
where it is located in society the odda
Sababa intersection is a picture of
rational order it's closer to the kind
that emerges in organic systems then the
kind that sprouts from a conceit of
comprehensive mastery perverse
consequences follow from trying to diss
burden us of exercising judgment this is
what we're doing when we entrust the
orchestration of daily life to systems
whether of painted lines or of
algorithms that are blind to the
extraordinary finesse of human beings in
coping with situations of fluid
uncertainty in concert with one another
infrastructure predicated on too rigid
an ideal of control fails to accommodate
the exercise of our human capacities or
to exploit the social efficiencies they
offer leading instead to the atrophy of
the human let us be more bold like the
Ethiopians I said a moment ago that if
forced to fit in today's available
political categories my argument here
would count as libertarian but this
needs a little elaboration because
clearly and not seeking simply to expand
the domain of choice as against
regulation rather I'm concerned with the
exercise of human capacity such as
prudence or judgment and sociality and
these fine little accommodation in the
market language of individual choice but
the argument is libertarian in a special
sense that may be unique
to the thought of Michael Oakshott the
English philosopher on the one hand he
takes liberty his central concern but on
the other hand he's a great defender of
tradition of customary practices not
because they're better than any possible
alternative but merely because they're
familiar somewhat like Edmund Burke he
sees the historical sediments and
inertia of custom as the best defensive
bulwark against the imposition of
rationalist dreams and it's these latter
that posed the real threat to Liberty
now if it's some late date in the future
a highly coordinated system of
autonomous cars or to achieve the level
of efficiency that prevails today at an
intersection in addis ababa it would be
counted a smashing success but to
achieve this miracle would require
massive expenditures by you and me and
the wholesale reworking of the urban
landscape according to the dictates of a
handful of private enterprises and their
fellow dreamers in the public sector so
what would that look like it looks very
similar autonomous intersection
management traffic control for the
future a project from the University of
Texas at Austin
most intersections today are controlled
by traffic signals stop signs or
roundabouts
however even when people do follow these
protocols intersections are the source
of much traffic congestion now a guy
contact even though they take up a small
percentage of the roadways roughly
one-quarter of all accidents and
one-third of all fatal accidents occur
at intersections it is now apparent that
the ton of Ascar well on their way to
becoming a reality at first they will
need to follow the same intersection
control protocols that were designed for
people but this project considers wants
most cars on the road are autonomous
whether we can do better than that by
way of an AI based coordination
mechanism you get the idea in this
research we introduced so multi mean
that video wasn't you know it's not
meant as parody but after watching the
artists Ababa intersection you know you
can kind of get the feeling that kind of
solving a non problem here Ivan Illich
offers the idea of a radical monopoly
which is not merely the predominance of
one firm to the exclusion of others but
a reordering of what's possible he
writes the establishment of radical
monopolies happens when people give up
their native ability to do what they can
for themselves and for each other
in exchange for something better that
can be done for them only by a major
tool he writes monopoly is hard to get
rid of when it has frozen not only the
shape of the physical world but also the
range of behavior enough imagination
radical monopoly has genuinely
discovered only when it's too late now
closely related to the idea of radical
monopoly a major tool in his usage is
one that makes us dependent on claims of
special expertise remote from our own
experience thus learning becomes the
monopoly of a regime of compulsory
schooling for example
in tending to the ills of the body
becomes nearly the exclusive preserve of
what we call the health care system we
forget how to do things for ourselves
and for one another he writes
institutions now optimize the output of
large tools for lifeless people by
contrast a pluralism of limited tools
that are directly intelligible support
what Ilic calls conviviality these are
individually accessible tools to support
the meaningful and responsible deeds of
fully awake people now loach was born in
1926 and published these words in 1973
one of the examples he gives of radical
monopolies is actually the automobile
he writes cars can thus monopolize
traffic they can shape the city into
their image practically ruling outlook
emotion by foot or by bicycle in Los
Angeles motor traffic curtails the right
to walk now this observation of his is
at the heart of what sometimes called
the New Urbanism that seeks to restore
walkability to cities and I'm very
sympathetic to this movement and the
argument I'm making here is closely
analogous if I can concede the apparent
irony of invoking the car haters basic
concerns but now on behalf of driving in
some respects the automobile is a major
tool in Ilic ascents compared to a
bicycle it ties us into dependence on
the expertise of others so even the
mechanic now relies on diagnostic
trouble codes that are the intellectual
property of the manufacturer or so the
car makers are trying to claim at least
right now and into a necessary system of
bureaucracy so the DMV with all its
hassles but the automobile is
nonetheless a tool that admits of
flexibility judgment and individual
initiative in its use in fact that's its
defect according to our utopians
an urban operating system of interlocked
autonomous cars would merely shift the
location of the governing algorithm from
painted lines curbs and enforcement
cameras to something machine executable
the spirit of it is the same the appeal
of automating our adherence to the
algorithm of course is to take
recalcitrant human beings out of the
picture entirely michel de certeau write
that wrote that walkers are
practitioners of the city for the city
is made to be walked I think that could
be said with equal justice of drivers
especially in a city such as la that was
made to be driven a New Year's Eve of
2018 Pope Francis expressed the ethical
significance of this in a homily at
Saint Peter's Basilica in which he
praised drivers who quote move in
traffic with good sense and prudence
prudence is a capacity for judgment that
we exercise when rules are inadequate to
guide our behavior it comes only from
experience and is cultivated only when
we're free-to-air he wrote these and a
thousand other behaviors expressed
concretely love for the city in a
beautiful phrase Francis suggested that
prudent drivers are artisans of the
common good who loved their city not
with words but with deeds from my own
travels I think some of the best urban
drivers I've seen it I've been in London
the give and take of the cabbies and
commuters as they jostle to advance is a
supple play of deference and assertion
professional courtesy and opportunities
seized the prizes traffic flow overrule
following traffic flow is a shared good
of an interesting sort it's a fragile
emergent property of a collective
a state that happens only if everyone is
paying attention to the situation and
brings a disposition of flexibility to
it at times it resembles an
improvisation among musicians urban
driving at its best is an experience of
civic friendship an act of trust and
solidarity that makes one proud to
belong to the human race rules become
more necessary as Trust and solidarity
decline in society and reciprocally the
proliferation of rules and the
disposition of rule following that they
encourage further erode our readiness to
extend to our fellow citizens a
presumption of competence and goodwill
driverless cars are programmed to follow
traffic rules to the letter an air on
the side of caution making them an
awkward fit to share the road with human
drivers the New York Times reported that
one Google car couldn't get through a
four-way stop because its sensors kept
waiting for other human drivers to stop
completely and let it go the human
drivers kept inching forward looking for
the advantage paralyzing Google's robot
of course what human drivers do is make
eye contact in such a situation or read
other cues of social interaction
allowing them to negotiate ambiguous
cases of right-of-way and work things
out on the fly some drivers are more
assertive others more defensive it's not
a stretch to say there's a kind of body
language of driving this kind of
improvisation works just fine for the
most part but social intelligence is
hard to reproduce with machine
executable logic therefore is concluded
human beings must become more like
machines in order to make the road more
hospitable to robots according to the
same Times article Dmitry Dolgov head of
software for Google's self-driving car
project that would be way moe said that
one thing he had learned from the
project was that human drivers needed to
quote less idiotic such an inference
comes easily when you conceive reason as
a computer scientist does as a social
and fundamentally rule like from such a
perspective human beings do indeed look
like inferior versions of computers it's
a theory of mind the basic assumptions
of which are shared by the discipline of
economics and enjoys a certain cultural
prestige behavioral economics shares
these assumptions and departs only by
emphasizing our failure to actually act
rationally that is as faithful
calculators of our own utility the
corollary which seems inescapable along
the intellectual axis that runs from
Silicon Valley to the rulemaking
apparatus of government is that life can
be improved by taking decision-making
away from individuals whether through
administrative nudges that are basically
algorithmic or through automation as
we've learned from studies of the
automated airplane cockpit in particular
one result of being thus relieved of the
exercise of our intelligence is that our
skills atrophy from lack of use leading
to demands for yet more automation
regarding the mind as an inept computer
becomes a self-fulfilling theory Iris
Murdoch wrote the man is the animal who
creates images of himself and then comes
to resemble the images I think it's in
this vicinity that we should look if we
want to understand why self-driving cars
played prominent roles in several
dystopian films including Blade Runner
Total Recall Minority Report in wall-e
and these films drivers have become
passengers and appear as a new class of
administrative subjects to be managed
now I use the word subject to mean both
an object of rule and the type of person
the form of subjectivity that is assumed
or required by such rule
and thereby brought into existence the
passengers detached isolated from others
whereas the give-and-take of urban
driving is a realm of interaction that
demands the skills of cooperation in
improvisation as such driving as a form
of organic civic life and the
disappearance of civic feeling as I
think key to the dystopian mood of these
films driving is a way of being with
others while having shared concrete
interests at stake
Tocqueville suggested that the habits of
collective self-government are
cultivated in practical activities that
demand cooperation and such habits are
indispensable to democratic political
culture but from the perspective of a
central power whether governmental or
technical commercial what is wanted is
an idealized subject of a different sort
an a social one who permits an atomized
account of human beings to be
operationalized there's an Iggy Pop song
or he sings I am a passenger I stay
under glass a society of such isolated
subjects will be more efficiently and
Playa bleah administrative all I want to
read you a passage from Michel Oakshott
published in 1956
now try listening to it imaginatively at
describing the response of some Google
apparatchik upon viewing the oddest
Ababa intersection video that I showed
you or a typical Street in London he
writes surveying the scene
some people are provoked by the absence
of order and coherence which appears to
them to be its dominant feature it's
wastefulness its frustration its
dissipation of human energy such people
are apt to exaggerate the current
disorder the absence of a plan is so
conspicuous that the small adjustments
and even the more the massive
arrangements
which restrained the chaos seemed to
them nugatory they have no feeling for
the warmth of untied eNOS but only for
its inconvenience but what's significant
is not the limitations of their powers
of observation but the turn of their
thoughts they feel that there ought to
be something that ought to be done to
convert this so-called chaos into order
for this is no way for rational human
beings to be spending their lives like
Apollo when he saw Daphne with her hair
hung carelessly about her back they sigh
and say to themselves what if it were
properly arranged
moreover they tell us that they have
seen in a dream
the glorious collisionless manner of
living proper to all mankind and this
dream they understand as their warrant
for seeking to remove the diversities
and occasions of conflict which
distinguish our current manner of living
it's a vision of human activity
coordinated and set going in a single
direction and of every resource being
used to the full and such people
understand the office of government to
be to turn a private dream into a public
and compulsory manner of living almost
finished here one theme that's emerged
with force in my inquiry into driving as
that of self-government broadly
understood both as an individual
capacity for self command and as a
political dispensation that we continue
to take for granted even as it erodes
under our feet the self government might
mean the ability to skillfully control
ones car the ability to temper ones
impatience with other drivers and the
ability to keep one's attention directed
to the road on one hand and on the other
hand larger questions such as who gets
to decide what sort of regime of
mobility will inhabit these different
scales on which we posed
question of self-government are surely
interlocked or imply one another for
example if we're so distracted behind
the wheel that we're already driving as
if our cars were self-driving this
suggests we need some benevolent entity
to step in and save us from ourselves by
automating a task that we're no longer
capable of doing for ourselves in
drawing a straight line from
self-command
to self-government in the political
sense I mean to claim the problem of
driving for the liberal Republican
tradition of political reflection this
tradition holds that the people worthy
of democracy must be made up of
individuals capable of governing their
own behavior in the first place and have
therefore earned their fellow citizens
trust when you're leaned into a blind
curve on a two lane country road on a
motorcycle it becomes very clear that
the road is a place of mutual trust this
is one of the most interesting things
about it driving is thus right for the
intention of political theorists who are
interested in what a Republican social
order looks like at the fine-grain let's
understand this fragile thing while it
still persists in such unobtrusive
pockets of daily life as driving such
pockets might hold clues that can guide
our hopes for the renewal of social
trust more broadly the possibility of
trust and cooperation has an intrinsic
reciprocal tie to the presumption of
individual competence taken together as
they must be these are the constituent
elements of self-government as a social
reality without which self-government as
a political form becomes untenable thank
you
Thank You dr. Crawford we'll be signing
copies of his books shop class as
Soulcraft as well as the world beyond
your head immediately following the
lecture we now have time for a few
questions please raise your hand and
wait for a microphone to be brought to
you hi thank you for your talk
I'm a little confused with the analogy
of the roadway so could you explain a
little bit more how I guess I just don't
understand how an efficient roadway that
runs smoothly with self-driving cars for
instance isn't also an example of beauty
and improvisation because yeah I guess I
guess for the programmers like there is
an amount of trust there that you have
to put in the people who programmed
wonder if you could explain that a
little bit more sure I mean you can't
think of it as a transfer of the
beautiful thing from the drivers to a
small cater of programmers and actually
one interesting thing about that video I
showed of you know the automated
intersection is precisely that it does
look like the oddest Sababa intersection
amazingly so at one level that would be
a big improvement over what we currently
have just sitting there to stop lie for
no reason so well then why worry about
it well I think that the stuff I read
from Ivan Illich gets at the reason
namely this kind of dis burdening us of
the exercise of judgment makes us
dependent on this major tool as to use
his term that is remote from what makes
us dependent on sort of special
expertise and I was trying to suggest
that that's worrying as a kind of
development in political psychology so
you know it could be that we could have
much more efficient traffic flow in
in areas be this whole vision were to
come to fruition and so one has to weigh
that I mean that's a very would be a
very real benefit which you know that's
what we're all talking about is that
benefit I'm trying to raise kind of a
different set of concerns I think we
need to bring to the table and that hi
thank you very much for your talk
I'm over here hi so I just had a
question similar to Dietrich's about the
intersections that you're talking about
earlier so the oddest about a
intersection you were talking about
since 2017 there's been 1500 deaths from
that intersection and it has a
population the entire country of about 3
million people
by contrast LA last year there was 244
deaths and the population of LA is 4
million so a million more okay so I
guess my question is it seems like this
rational order that we have in America
has to a very large extent helped saved
lives so why would we not advocate for
something like AI that would probably
with self-driving cars not only help
save lives but also increase efficiency
use to share
no it's like once the safety thing comes
up everything crumbles everything that
is the Democratic morality is safety
it's interesting so what I should have
done is showed an intersection in
Southeast Asia which would have looked
nearly identical traffic fatalities
there are dramatically lower than the
u.s. now that's an interesting question
how that can be has something to do with
the culture I suppose but no that is a
fair objection I didn't know that I
didn't know the stats for Ethiopia in
particular but I do know that in some of
those African cities it's very high so
yeah safety that's obviously the most
massive consideration that gets invoked
to stop any any sort of these further
considerations and it's you know it's a
very real one you don't want to be
dismissive about it but it's also true
that I think we're getting dumber and
dumber
let me let me bring in another sort of
safety thing because I think it's a
legitimate concern I ride a motorcycle
that's that's my usual commuting I mean
put in a lot of miles track of
motorcycle deaths shot up dramatically
right starting right after 2007 just
when the smartphone appeared so people
are so enthralled watching the cat
videos on YouTube that they can't be
bothered to watch the road one way to
view the autonomous car push is that
it's Silicon Valley trying to solve a
problem that it created you know which I
appreciate but we've sort of trained
ourselves into being so careless that
it's a very real question whether
American drivers could
handle anything like the artists about
the intersection I don't think we could
I think we've kind of were that bad at
this point but I don't know maybe I mean
Germany actually yeah and Germany has a
real driving culture where you know
famously the Autobahn there's no speed
limit and you know what people do they
stay on the right unless they're going
like a hundred and thirty miles an hour
and it's like there's a sorting people
sort themselves out and they're paying
attention they're looking in their
mirror like everybody's on the same page
a less extreme version of that
California is the one state in the
nation where it's legal to split lanes
for a motorcycle which is done
everywhere in the world but not in the
US but it is in California and you know
what motorists actually have been
trained to do that interesting story
the folklore among motorcyclists is that
it was the CHP the Highway Patrol that
lobbied to make it legal in California
because they patrol on bikes and they've
reasoned that motors would be trained to
look for cyclists if everyone was doing
it and it I think it was successful so
I'll stop yeah my name is Ellie I'm a
sophomore here and just kind of on the
topic of that driving metaphor I
actually spent a month in China riding
taxis around some of the busiest cities
in that country and while what you said
that trust indifference is definitely
present there are also half our traffic
jams and just kind of on that metaphor I
was wondering if humans are as naturally
coordinated and cooperative as we like
to think they are or is there a certain
amount of regulation well well there is
that but also are we naturally inclined
to live communally and defer to one
another and trust one another
that's something that has to be taught I
think there are big cultural differences
on that and clearly I think the the very
low death rate from traffic in Southeast
Asia is probably good index of how
that's true I had a thought but I've
sort of dropped it so remind me your
questions it's briefly again I'm sorry
my question was our human beings
naturally cooperative - yes good yeah
well road rage is actually a very
interesting phenomena this something
about getting in your car that brings
out the monster in people I mean I'm
very much that way myself so I painted
it B now st. you Pope Francis you know
nice drivers but there's this whole
other side right and it's it's like it's
it's like individualism on steroids
because you're isolated from other
people you can safely give anyone the
finger you're so you is like this is
kind of like a sense of entitlement that
gets supercharged when you're behind the
wheel but I wanted to go back to like
you the Hat you know there's been like
week-long traffic jams in China where
people die of starvation that's a real
thing one of the most robust findings of
the traffic engineers is that when you
increase Road capacity you just get more
flow because it's reducing the cost in
time you know to commute and so they
finally figured out the adding and road
you know adding more lanes does not help
your congestion problem this is so your
mention of the the traffic jam prompted
that turns out you know when uber came
into New York City and of course a lot
of the rhetoric surrounding it's weird
the issue of ride hailing and autonomous
cars and electric cars get all
mixed up in the sort of journalistic
hype about these things were the really
very distinct issues
uber is hugely convenient it's also been
a huge increase in congestion in
Manhattan because the island is flooded
with empty ubers trolling for cab I mean
for fares which is precisely why you can
get one so quickly there's all these
black cars trolling around so the mayor
is what was this in the bloomberg know I
think was under the new guy yeah de
Blasio this became like a real issue in
fact that was why they were trying to
kick her out of New York City it wasn't
so much the taxi Lobby as it was a
congestion issue it's not really related
look we have a question in the back yeah
hi thank you very much for your time
this is kind of going away from traffic
intersections and more to a general
question do you believe that there are
some truly valuable benefits to modern
technological advances or do you see do
you believe that those benefits rarely
outweigh the fact that self-government
is at stake and if so what do those
benefits look like because we need
progress but when do you believe that
progress is going too far
thank you well I mean obviously you have
to assess these things individually I'm
a big believer in electronic fuel
injection as compared to a couple
carburetors that's a technological
progress and it's not you know it's not
dese killing anybody or making anybody
dumb so yeah I mean there's you know
there's this kind of impulse to
categorize people as technophobes or
technophiles and that's that's obviously
pretty dumb so all I could say is you
know case by case
question on the speakers left yeah thank
you so much for your talk dr. Crawford
my name is Spencer I'm a sophomore here
studying chemistry I'm sorry I didn't
mean to say that your question was dumb
I hope that's not what that sounded like
I want to clarify that yeah go ahead
you talked about how technological
advances tend to encourage us to cede
control or see the ability to make
judgments I wondered if you could talk
about from the more your political
philosophy side what do you see is like
some of the the negative implications of
that when we begin to like seed this
control and you know cease to cease to
to exercise that judgment what happens
to us as people in that situation that
makes sense thank you I think there's an
obvious kind of the modern personality
getting reformed in the direction of
passivity and dependence and that's
visible and a lot of fronts but I think
most prominently in our relation to
material reality I mean just your
dependent and all these things in your
life that you have no idea how they work
how to fix them
never mind like we built building one
yourself so you know it's a kind of
existential state of mystification where
technology really is like magic and
you're the whole point of modernity is
that we got away from magic right it was
about reason so where's the space for
for human reason if you're living in a
magical world it's like a back in the
Middle Ages or something so that's
that's something
you know hi there so thanks I was
reading an article this morning in
Psychology Today
apparently depression can be attributed
to inflamed inflammation in the body now
like not even in your brain but
elsewhere in your body well yeah yeah
inflammation in the body in general I I
can't I can't help but think that this
problem with AI and the problem with
traffic and so forth and deaths and
safety is sort of reminiscent or a
reflective of social science in general
and and the objective of sort of
controlling and managing ourselves and I
guess I'm wondering to what extent you
think these problems and these
difficulties extended adjust the tension
we have and being who we are which is
not entirely rational quite quite in
fact infused or suffused with emotion we
don't want to die we don't want to be
depressed we don't want to feel guilty
we don't want to self criticise and so
we're groping after ways of like
relieving ourselves at these tensions so
it seems to me that this this AI problem
overlaps significantly with just sort of
the existential difficulty of being
human that we somehow have never
reconciled with yeah I like that and and
maybe one kind of gloss on that might be
tit I mean you mentioned social science
which often shades into a kind of social
engineering and I think the mentality
that guides our our technocrat masters
and whether Silicon Valley or the
administrative state is to regard
everything as kind of under the under
the rubric of problem solving problems
to be solved and of course there are
some aspects of human existence don't
admit of that kind of
understanding I know if that is it all
adjacent to what you were saying but
yeah we have a question on the speakers
left yeah so I have a question so you
seem to focus a lot about law on
self-government the difference between
sort of the chaotic beauty and the
rational regulations that we already
have
not counting the imposition of AI so I
was wondering what you thought about the
difference between sort of the social
aspect of self-government and maybe a
personal aspect of like rule-following
patience and you were talking about
entitlement in road rage yeah well thank
you for that I do think the I tried to
say that self command of the individual
is indispensable at a precondition for
self government as a political form not
least because we have to trust that our
fellow citizens have you know aren't
going to do things like drive on the
wrong side of the yellow line when
you're going around a blind curve or not
be so distracted behind the wheel that
they run into you so that means having
the self command to keep your attention
on the road so yeah and I think this is
I mean this is a long part of the like I
think I called it a liberal Republican
tradition of kind of puts an Asterix on
the democratic ideal and says that to be
worthy of demócrata chol sense of people
has to be capable of its kind of
self-command so this would be you know
this in now you're you're talking about
virtue right your so strictly liberal
democracy tries to bracket the issue of
virtue and say that it's
somehow not the concern it's not a
public concern but you know obviously
I'm now touching on a vast literature
here but the idea of what what what are
the sort of cultural underpinnings of
democratic culture that aren't
themselves simply democratic but depend
on some cultural capital of virtue that
would be one way to think about it we
have time for one more question hi thank
you for your talk what do you see as the
way that an individual can approach
these problems because some of these are
like larger issues about like traffic
laws and things that we as an individual
can't necessarily just like change
tomorrow so what are things that
individuals can do yeah have a good
answer to that but I but that the spirit
of the question I think is important
because I think people do feel powerless
there's a kind of ideology of inevitable
ism that is you know repeated you know
driverless cars are coming there's
nothing you can do about it the AI you
know as though it was simply like
physics working itself out but this is
very much it's a new form of capitalism
that we're living under so I I can't get
it give up the mic without mentioning a
book that has just come out I have
already read it cuz I got an advance
copy that's called the age of
surveillance capitalism and it's to my
mind the most successful attempt to
understand what's really a new form of
political economy that is very new in
the world has become very powerful that
bears little resemblance to sort of
conventional sort of
profit motive sort of thinking I'm not
going to try to give us a synopsis of it
at 600 pages but I think it's a book
it's a book that once you've read it it
gives you a new lens for to see
contemporary economy and everything kind
of comes into focus but one upshot of
that is that this kind of feeling of
inevitability that we have and
powerlessness is very much something
that's cultivated as a strategy for kind
of wearing down popular resistance for
things that are not responses to market
demand that kind of top-down projects
very kind of authoritarian and creepy I
really like the idea of ending on the
word creepy here so yeah thank you
we are going to finish actually with one
more question one more question
okay Oh mister yeah while I think of it
well I well I say the question you
should think of a way to use the word
creepy as your last word okay so I'm a
fellow motorcyclist with you and I've
written many miles between the cars in
Los Angeles and actually think it's
pretty safe but you know if you do it
right but I've always loved the idea of
self-driving cars and I you made me feel
like a bad citizen but the reason is I'm
busy you could do something else what
about that argument
yeah well that's you know when you so
the promotional literature sometimes he
adds like Volvo had one for a while
further self-driving car project and it
usually shows a guy holding what looks
like a small volume of poetry as he goes
down the highway and that's that's
conceivable you you could be doing that
or or it may you know it may be that
you're surfing the web and then the
rational part of it is that those 46
minutes of the average American commute
in both directions are now available for
your attention to be auctioned off to
the highest bidder
on the internet that might be part of it
is to and another rationale
business-wise is that your location and
movements through space are one of the
most valuable bits of behavioral data
about you for predicting your behavior
and then in turn manipulating it so
there's that element to but but yeah
soap you did a survey of drivers this is
interesting and they asked people what
is the your ideal commute in terms of
length and the answer was not zero it
was I think 20 minutes
so people seem to value this time
they're in the car now
you know if it's self-driving you would
still have that time so this doesn't
really get to your point but it is
interesting that people kind of value
that time in their car between work and
home you can decompress you listen to
your music it's the time between work
and the second shift which is home life
right if you're two working parents so
this idea that driving is pure drudgery
is one of the mains or rhetorical points
made you know when the Silicon Valley
people are pushing this and you know
there's obviously some truth of that
that's not the whole truth
creepy
you